[Music]
the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
on politics now the race for governor we
dig into the highlight of the republican
primary debate held here on channel 8
this week plus
small businesses have been really
impacted during the pandemic
a closer look at the lieutenant
governor's race what the office does and
the current lieutenant governor's hopes
for keeping her job
plus the debate in washington d.c how to
stop mass shootings efforts by lawmakers
to try and restrict gun sales
from eight news now
this is politics now
[Music]
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler this week
eight news now hosted the state's only
televised republican gubernatorial
debate featuring the top five candidates
clark county sheriff joe lombardo and
attorney joey gilbert are the front
runners former senator dean heller and
north las vegas mayor john lee were sort
of on a second tier venture capitalist
guinea nora is in fifth place in recent
polling out of the gate moderators asked
the candidates to address school safety
after this week's deadly school shooting
in texas
what would you do to protect children
and staff in schools from mass shootings
like this one mental health services
we are lacking the commonality of most
of these
tragic shootings on these mass shootings
is the nexus being
mental health
and the lack of resources to address the
individuals the mental health issue in
the state of nevada were last in the
nation for mental health
resources for children teenagers and
adults are lacking in las vegas where if
two mental health facilities overstaffed
and don't have enough resources we need
to do a better job there i would fully
fund public safety we have the money
we're just not using it properly so i
would use the people's money to secure
our most prized asset our children you
take a look at the washington post
washington post did a story this week on
the clark county school district down
here and how dangerous it is and the
teachers are the ones that are being
targeted now with clubs with knives with
sexual assault even students raping
teachers this has to change it's time to
break up this school district i think we
need to include also when we talk about
mental health more in parent involvement
in what's going on at our schools and i
also believe we need to break up school
district
i want to start something called the
battle born marshals
and battleborn marshals are going to
report to the department of safety and
they're going to go out to the 664
schools
and they're going to be marshals the way
we the same way we have them on our
airlines and that's how we're going to
define them from these lunatics that go
in
and prey on children
now sheriff lombardo leads the polling
right now he is endorsed by former
president donald trump and that made him
a target for the other candidates they
attacked him on immigration and ending
metro police's cooperation program with
federal immigration officials that
following a federal court ruling gilbert
heller and lee call him sanctuary joe
would you activate and send nevada
national guard troops to the southern
border
first off
that's a very good question every 15
days 275 000 people are coming across
the border into our country that's as
big as north las vegas is just so you
can get an understanding of what we're
creating we don't have the services we
don't have the schools we don't have the
health care to take care of all these
people i would put my
national guard people at risk
of
the state issues to send them down to
the border to see what we could do to
slow down what's going on with that
migrating no
there's a finite amount of money i was
actually a
military officer in the nevada national
guard there's a finite amount of money
associated with the deployment of their
local state guard and i am the only one
standing up here at this podium that has
removed anybody who has committed crimes
associated with and being undocumented
illegal absolutely without a doubt i
would deploy the troops but
unfortunately sheriff lombardo you know
we refer to him among us as sanctuary
joe for a reason department of justice
inspector general's report 2016 had
clark county is one of the worst
sanctuary counties in the nation i would
but let's let's be clear joe's not
telling the truth here
what happened with he made southern
nevada a sanctuary city if you want to
live in a dangerous neighborhood live in
a sanctuary city and that's what this
guy costs you don't have to have the
legislature deem us a sanctuary city
well candidates wrapped up with heller
attacking lombardo and lombardo declared
the primary already over
i stand in front of you today
a successful businessman who's lived the
american dream
and i'm running for governor so that
each and everyone in nevada has the
opportunity to live the american dream i
think good government is the way to
handle these things and not poor
business practices and that's what our
city of north las vegas is doing i can
fix nevada what nevada needs is a proven
conservative i've spent a career cutting
taxes reducing the size of government
and looking for relief for nevada's
nevadans hard-working families what are
we going to get in november do you want
a proven conservative i've proven the
past 27 months i've been fighting for
nevadans on my own time in my own time i
got the churches open i got early
treatment medication the mass off the
children this primary is over
there's nothing more to argue about i've
weathered 12 months of attacks from
steve syslak in his packs and for most
of the individuals standing here next to
me so we need to call get come together
early voting is underway now in the june
primary election mail-in ballots they're
already arrived you may have gotten
yours already early voting runs until
june 10th
primary day is june 14th you can vote at
any early voting location you can also
send in your mail-in ballot you can also
drop it off at any of the locations
around clark county nevada does offer
same-day registration you can register
at one of those sites as well or you can
do it online
this week clark county election
officials gave us a look inside where
all your votes are being counted if you
drop off a mail ballot you do have to
sign a form saying you're not going to
vote twice that's not allowed of course
clark county registrar of voters joe
gloria tried to assure any skeptical
voters
i think what's important for us is to
demonstrate to all voters that there's
integrity in our process if anybody's
concerned about elections we ask you to
go to the source
and if you have other questions gloria
encourages you to check out the nevada
secretary of state's website for
information
one of the most competitive races on
really both sides of the political aisle
is the lieutenant governor's race on the
republican side las vegas city
councilman stavros anthony former state
treasurer dan schwartz and businessman
john miller and mac miller are the front
runners of a seven candidate field on
the democratic side current lieutenant
governor lisa cannell burkhead well
she's a former teacher she's already in
the position she hasn't been there very
long though keno burkhead was appointed
by governor sisolak back in december
challenging her is henderson mayor
deborah march and head of the nevada
democratic rural caucus kimmy cole
governor sisolak has endorsed his
appointment keno burkhead and this week
he sent out some flyers to support her
as well cano burkhead was a principal
she was an educator in the clark county
school school district for close to
three decades i spoke with her about
what she's accomplished and the work she
says she has
let's talk about your accomplishments
what you've been able to achieve in your
time as lieutenant governor thank you
i'm really proud of the work that we've
done around the office of small business
advocacy
which just launched in february
and the work and the idea behind that is
really to be a one-stop shop for our
small business owners in removing the
barriers that sometimes hinder the
success of our small business owners and
so
we have been able to
connect with their small business owners
kind of direct them to some grant
opportunities and that really helped
them to open their doors we know that
our small businesses have been really
impacted during the pandemic another uh
sort of key component of the lieutenant
governor's position is the office of
tourism yes obviously las vegas and
nevada in general have a lot of tourists
uh what would you like to do moving
forward if you're again retained as
lieutenant governor to enhance travel
nevada to try and get the word out more
maybe not just about las vegas but other
parts of the state we've already been
doing that so i've been working with
travel nevada around because i do chair
the um outdoor recreation space and so
really working
to
in state encourage nevadans to discover
nevada and all of what i call the gems
that we have in our outdoor spaces in
nevada but also to invite our latin
american and our asian
markets to our state to las vegas but
also to explore and to discover nevada
so that's already happening
i've been working with travel nevada
i've been working alongside some
influencers
in mexico around this idea of coming out
i've recorded videos in spanish and sent
them to our latin american countries to
encourage them to come and to discover
the great spaces that we have outdoors
in our state your background is in
education
25 years i believe it is with clark
county school district and elsewhere
mental health is such a big component of
what's going on in our schools we know
that the classes just wrapped up this
week
what would you be able to do would you
like to do up in carson city and
lieutenant governor's office to try and
get more resources or what can be done
to get more resources into the classroom
yeah we've already started with
roundtable sessions that we've had
alongside our state superintendent
with our stakeholders with parents with
our educators really talking about the
crisis that we're having and how we can
then take that feedback of their real
experiences the parents the educators to
have those conv conversations at a state
level so that we can be really targeted
in our approach right be very strategic
with our funding making sure that we are
spending money in ways that really
impact students i have always said that
when our adults on campus
are okay then our kids are okay and
right now our adults on campus are not
okay and so we need to take that into
consideration we need to make sure that
we are all of the adults all of the
talent in our state around the table
having these crucial conversations we're
in a crisis in education we're losing
teachers
we
already have vacancies that we can't
fill and so we need to make sure that we
are addressing the issues at hand
our full interview with the lieutenant
governor is available on eight newsnow
dot com we should point out we have
reached out to henderson mayor deborah
march who is the other democratic
front-runner running in for this
position she has not gotten back to us
the main jobs for lieutenant governor
are economic development and tourism
they would also take over for the
governor if he or she cannot do their
job for whatever reason they preside
over the state senate and cast a
deciding vote whenever there might be a
tie
the debate over how to stop mass
shootings next on politics now the
divide between democrats and republicans
in congress after the tragedy in texas
information go to shophottabs.com
welcome back to politics now
outrage and grief after this week's mass
shooting at a texas elementary school in
washington d.c democrats are renewing
calls for gun control measures
republicans are offering other solutions
19 children were killed in the attack
two adults teachers were also killed
it's the deadliest school shooting in
the u.s since sandy hook for years
democrats have pushed for measures like
universal background checks and renewing
the federal assault weapons ban
republicans say such restrictions don't
work instead they're pushing for more
armed law enforcement on campuses
why do you go through all the hassle
of getting this job if your answer
is that as this slaughter increases as
our kids run for their lives we do
nothing there's generally a mental
illness factor to it
texas has sparked a lot of movement in
washington dc alex simone joining us now
from washington to talk about where
things stand right now on capitol hill
alex the democrats are proposing more
new gun legislation what are they trying
to do legislatively to react to what
took place in texas
hey john that's right we really have
seen a strong concerted effort from
democrats to try to get some new gun
safety laws on the books in fact earlier
in the week president joe biden said
that said in a tweet that you know when
the federal assault weapon ban was in
effect mass shootings decreased and when
that assault weapon ban expired mass
shootings tripled in this country and so
if democrats
want things to change they say you need
to get some new gun safety laws on the
books one of the things they have been
pushing for for example is renewing that
federal assault weapon ban but that's
not the only thing they say also things
like
banning high capacity magazine clips
things like you know magazines that can
hold 50 or more bullets at a time we of
course have heard you know pushback from
republicans who at least so far don't
seem like they are on board for
supporting these measures
they say that they don't want to
infringe on the rights of law-abiding
citizens
because they don't believe that will
make a difference in stemming the mass
shootings that really you only see
happen time and time again in this
country and you know we had our own mass
shooting here in las vegas and even
after that there was legislative talk in
capitol hill and
they sometimes go places sometimes they
don't republicans don't seem too keen on
what the democrats are suggesting now so
what is the gop proposing
yeah republicans have their own ideas
like i said they said one focus should
be the issue of mental health
though they're still exploring that idea
i haven't you know particularly heard
them
mention any concrete ways of how you
deal with that when it comes to linking
it and stemming the gun violence that we
see another thing or several other
things they have proposed though are
is this idea of hardening schools and so
implementing measures like bulletproof
doors and windows or systems that can
alert people about mass shootings
we should point out nevada requires a
background check on private party to
private party sales of guns that ballot
initiative on this passed by one
percentage point back in 2018 lawmakers
tweaked it so the state not the fbi runs
the background checks then kicked it
kicked in rather in january of 2020. we
also have a red flag law that allows a
court order seizing firearms to do that
for up to a year
next on politics now affordable housing
for the military we'll speak with
senator jackie rosen she tells us what's
being done to help military families
handle rising housing costs
and drawing back international visitors
what the homeland security committee
came up with during a meeting in las
vegas this week
[Music]
you're watching politics now
military life is a challenge there are
deployments to different bases the act
of moving is a challenge of its own and
it's expensive but the military pays for
transitions but that money used to only
arrive after the fact now nevada senator
jackie rosen is working on getting that
money to service men and women faster i
spoke with her about that issue and the
effort to make nevada first in the next
presidential primary
one thing they kept saying over and over
was that transition money that they need
when they live on base to moving off
base they weren't getting it until
months after they moved now of course in
2020 we allocated this money but i'm
sure any viewer out there everybody has
moved we know how expensive it is we
know you have first month rent security
deposit moving expenses so these young
servicemen and women
weren't getting it ahead of time causing
them to have to ask friends or family to
borrow the money making it very
stressful for them to move so of course
through committee hearings through
letters through talking to the
secretaries of all the services not just
the air force
the pentagon department of defense
indicated to us or they told everyone
about a week ago that they heard what we
said they took it into account they're
changing the policy now they're the
money's already allocated cost nothing
they'll be able to get the money before
they move it's a great change we should
see the date they've notified all the
services so now we're just waiting to
see the actual date of implementation it
should be uh fairly quickly
it seems unusual that if the money was
already allocated
was it just the policy was we'll give it
you know send you send us the invoice
and we'll give you money versus the
other way around you already had to go
do it you had to send the invoice
instead of saying i'm signing a lease
here's the lease i'm signing while
you're doing it so you could have the
money uh given to you right at that time
i remember reading a gao report
from a year or so ago maybe two years
ago and they were talking about that a
creature there's very little places to
live up in indian springs um
are there any efforts as you were saying
talking to the the folks up at creech
of trying to address that um the city of
las vegas wants to build more homes in
the northwest valley that's still a long
drive up to indian springs are there any
efforts and being under undertaken in
washington to do something about that
well we've been talking actually uh
locally i think that creech has been
talking with
the city of las vegas the clark county
to try to work on a plan to develop
affordable housing units right up around
creech and of course my job in the
federal government is to make sure that
we have funding for military
construction and so whether that's
adjacent to the base or on the base for
creech it might have to be adjacent to
because of the size and the location on
nellis we do have the space there's some
barracks that just need to be upgraded
and there's other things we need to
build primary season in nevada is only a
couple of weeks away
you're involved in trying to get nevada
to be first in the presidential primary
for 2024. there's an important deadline
on the horizon
where do things stand with the
application is it just sort of a waiting
game now
well it's been a team effort we have
submitted the application for nevada and
done all of our advocating i can tell
you that i think nevada of course we
know our model battle born but we're
battleground and the road to the
presidency regardless of party runs
straight through nevada and we really
look like the rest of the country and
our ethnic diversity in our uh in our
energy we have wind water solar
geothermal we have a 30 hispanic
population about 10 african american
we're uh fastest growing aapi one of the
fastest growing in the nation we are
union strong
we have so much going on in nevada that
i think we would be at the best place to
have first in the nation we'll see what
they decide coming up their decision
will be sometime next month and we'll
just look forward to hearing what that
is
a final decision on which states will
enter the early window for the
presidential primary that's expected to
come at the democratic national
committee meeting which is scheduled for
july 8th and 9th
international travel still has not
caught back up to its pre-pandemic pace
this week congress's homeland security
committee was here in las vegas figuring
out how to make travelers feel more
comfortable the members met over at
harry reid international airport in a
meeting and that was hosted by nevada
democratic congresswoman dina titus she
says some travelers are staying away
because they're confused about
international rules on coronavirus
vaccines and masking
all of those things are good tools in
the toolbox but we need to get the
message out especially internationally
this is what you have to do to come
new technologies like biometric
screenings have really helped airports
decrease those wait times but the head
of tsa and border patrol for nevada say
we're also they're also experiencing
rather staffing shortages turnover is as
high as 25 percent in those agencies
more politics now
only at your las vegas area hyundai
dealer
in what to watch early voting and
mail-in ballots now in past elections as
many as two-thirds of nevadans have
voted before the actual election day so
we're going to watch and see if those
trends hold firm and whether any
problems might pop up with mail-in
ballots this primary election
making our case in a little more than a
month nevada might be declared the first
state to nominate a democratic
presidential candidate in 2024 just for
firm senator jackie rosen on that issue
so we're staying on top of that as well
and when something develops we will
certainly let you know we thank you so
much for watching us here on politics
now don't forget all the latest
political news at eight newsnow dot com
it's all there for you we're back with
you next saturday thank you very much
for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]